chelsea handler summed this up the
chelsea handler is that
i guess comedian is she a comedian she's
this white comedian
who said she got very angry at her
ex-boyfriend fitty cent
because fiddy sent said he's going to
vote for trump
and and he explained why he's going to
vote for trump he said he's going to
vote for trump because trump is going to
keep his taxes relatively low and joe
biden is going to raise his taxes so
significantly that fitty cent would
become 20 cent
so he gave his reasoning chelsea and was
so upset
that that she had to call and remind him
that he's black
that blacks aren't allowed to vote for
conservatives they have to vote for
democrats
you heard about my ex boyfriend right 50
cent and his support
of of uh donald trump yeah what's going
on between you i saw your
tweets and i go wait what's happening
because you said he was your favorite
ex-boyfriend and then he what is he
supporting trump
he says he doesn't want to pay 62
percent of taxes which by the way isn't
a plan of
joe biden's that's that's that's a lie
so he doesn't want to pay 62 percent of
taxes because he doesn't want to go from
being
50 to 20 and i
and i had to remind him that he was a
black person
so he can't vote for donald trump and
that he shouldn't be influencing
an entire swath of people who may listen
to him
because he's worried about his own
personal pocketbook so
i haven't heard back from him yet but i
am willing to
you know seal the deal in more ways than
one if he changes his mind and publicly
denounces donald trump i might be
willing to go for another spin if you
know what i'm talking about
everything about that is disgusting
everything first of all the idea that
chelsea handler
who you know how do i say this
respectfully
no spring chicken okay anymore is
going to prostitute herself so that this
guy will vote for biden
is gross it's gross to think about it's
gross to do
the statement that this this white
liberal
is going to lecture a black man on how
because of his skin color he's not
allowed to vote
for republicans is gross
it's disgusting it's obviously untrue
the idea that joe biden won't raise some
people's taxes to 62 percent
she said that that's a lie that's not a
lie it's true it's true the reason she
doesn't understand this
is because she i guess she thinks
there's only such a thing as federal
taxes
but there are state and local taxes too
when you add it up in places like
california
the biden tax plan comes out for many
people including 50 cent
to 62 or maybe 63 actually
well the whole thing is gross but in
that in that whole
gross monologue to jimmy fallon who was
just as confused he goes
huh he's voting for trump huh what
that's so weird
in that whole monologue she never
explains
why fitty cent has to vote for biden
why all black people have to vote for
democrats why
she just makes a lot of insinuations
well
he's black i mean it's like i don't even
need to explain it
no you do explain it to me explain to me
why anybody should vote for biden well
trump's bad
he okay yeah i got it you think trump's
really bad put that over here for a
second
why should i vote for joe biden instead
of just voting against donald trump i
actually think it's legitimate to vote
against candidates
but just just as an intellectual
exercise
why do you why would you vote for this
guy
trump puts kids in cages no he didn't
joe biden actually started that but
that's fine neither here nor there
why would you vote for joe biden they
can't give you an answer because joe
biden himself is not for
anything joe biden licks that finger
puts it up in the wind and blows around
that's why he is a low energy candidate
to use the term that was applied to jeb
bush in
in 2016. jeb bush stood for a lot more
than joe biden ever has
he's a low energy because he can't take
a position
the one time he gets backed into taking
a position it's on an issue that could
cost him the election
particularly in pennsylvania you see
the dilemma what is joe four or nothing
at all what are you for
what are you for less than two weeks
until the election
i hope you enjoyed that short segment
from the michael knowles show be sure to
check out the full episode linked in the
description or
download the podcast wherever you listen
to podcasts
[Music]
you